le 22 février 2019 une annonce va
déclencher la colère de la rue
algérienne
le président abdelaziz bouteflika
particulièrement affaibli fait part de
son souhait de briguer un cinquième
mandat
dans la foulée des milliers d'algériens
en descendre manifester dans les rues
des grandes villes du pays le mouvement
d'hui raccroc racines et va entraîner la
chute du chef de l'état algérien
le 11 mars abdelaziz bouteflika renonce
d'abord à se présenter à la
présidentielle
la volonté de l'irak est en partie que
c'est le 2 avril 2019 abdelaziz
bouteflika accepte de démissionner mais
pour les manifestants c'est insuffisant
ils réclament le départ des proches du
président démissionnaire ainsi que des
généraux qui dirigent le pays en
coulisses abdelkader bensalah est nommé
président par intérim le 9 avril 2019
deux mois plus tard il appelle un
dialogue lors d'un discours télévisé
après le report de la présidentielle
je vous appelle tous à opter pour la
voie du dialogue inclusif en vue de
tracer une feuille de route devant aider
à l'organisation par l'état du scrutin
dans les meilleurs délais dans la rue le
ira continue de maintenir la pression
des manifestations pacifiques se
déroulent tous les vendredis en
particulier à alger la présidentielle
est finalement fixé à la fin 2019
le 12 décembre 2019 abdelmadjid tebboune
en anciens fidèles d'abdelaziz
bouteflika remporte une présidentielle
massivement boycotté par l'opposition
il propose d'organiser un référendum
constitutionnel
près d'un an plus tard le 1er novembre
2000 vend une révision constitutionnelle
est approuvée par référendum en scrutin
marqué par le taux d'abstention le plus
élevé de l'histoire de l'algérie
le référendum se tient en l'absence du
chef de l'état attendu cofidis
fait hospitaliser en allemagne
abdelmadjid tebboune revient brièvement
à alger en décembre 2020 avant d'aller à
nouveau se faire soigner à berlin il
réapparaît à la télévision algérienne le
tous février dernier en retour aux
commandes du pays quelques jours avant
une reprise des manifestations le 16
février des milliers de personnes
manifestent à kherrata pour le deuxième
anniversaire du irak
là où avait eu lieu la première marche
deux jours plus tard le président
tebboune tends la main à l'opposition et
grassi des dizaines de prisonniers
politiques
il annonce également la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale populaire et l'intérêt va pour
appeler à des élections issoire
affranchi de l'argent qu'ils viennent de
la correction ou non david ouvrir les
portes à la jeunesse chabab à cette
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
s'ajoute un remaniement ministériel sans
changements majeurs
pas de quoi calmer les revendications de
l'opposition qui appellent à manifester
ce lundi partout en algérie